all 50 u.s states are on high alert this
weekend for fear of armed protests
against the election of joe biden as
president around 25 000
national guard troops are being sent to
help secure the capital
washington d.c before wednesday's
inauguration
it's feared violent extremist groups are
targeting the city
the fbi has also warned of possible
protests in
every state capital
[Music]
they're heading to washington d.c from
all over the country
national guard troops in this case from
washington state in the far northwest of
the u.s
they'll join thousands of other
so-called weekend warriors
to secure the inauguration all of them
military-trained men
and women given time away from their
regular jobs to serve where needed
their presence is requested in the
capital city and much appreciated
by capitol police who were overrun on
january 6th
in a siege of the capitol building
they're also appreciated by residents
here
in the back of your head you know why
they're here and that's a little bit
you know nerve-wracking and also you
know disappointing that
the city's sort of been turned upside
down as a result of what happened
a couple weeks ago it's been really
scary because we're concerned not only
for the capital in the buildings the
white house
the neighborhoods because we live just
very very close to here
the stage is set on the steps of the
capitol building for wednesday's
inauguration ceremony
an event that normally draws tens or
hundreds of thousands
this time the numbers will be sharply
reduced indeed most thoroughfares
including pennsylvania avenue
you know american terrorists that were
trying to you know create
problems it's not only washington d.c
concerned about violent attack
minnesota's snowy capital indeed the
capitals of all 50 states
are beefing up security for protests
that could go well beyond the ordinary
remaining national guard are on standby
should the run-up to the presidential
inauguration
or the day itself turn ugly
i'm joined now by taylor millard his
correspondent for nbc news radio in
dallas texas
taylor all 50 states on high alert now
for armed protests
this weekend what's the situation where
you are in texas
well there were some protesters who
showed up at the
texas state capitol on saturday they
discovered a very closed capital the
state capitol was closed down
on friday just days after it actually
reopened to the public for the start of
the
latest legislative session the texas
house gop
which is the ruling party in the state
government
has said it's a temporary situation and
they expect the capital
to be back open soon there are thousands
of national guard troops now in
washington to secure the biden ignore
inauguration on wednesday we've seen
amazing pictures of them sleeping inside
the capitol building and how do
americans feel about seeing their
capital under what is essentially a
military lockdown
it's a pretty interesting situation to
see a lot of people
are pretty freaked out by it or at least
sorry and annoyed that dc
is in lockdown i've talked to a couple
people in dc who said they're completely
over the situation they want the area to
open back
up it's a little unnerving when you see
roads blocked and bridges shut down
the national mall closed and you know
people are just tired of it they're
ready to get back to
some semblance of normal you can imagine
now
once joe biden is indeed inaugurated on
wednesday do you think the situation
will improve there
gradual acceptance among trump
supporters that he has lost and that
biden is the legitimate president
one would think so there are trump
supporters already on social media who
are saying okay it's time to focus on
the next election which is obviously
2022
and getting a republican majority in the
house
and senate are there obviously still
going to be some hold out to
believe that the president that uh
president-elect joe biden was
illegitimately elected
obviously there are investigations which
have happened
into whether voter fraud was found or
not and nobody's found anything
one thing the republican party is
expected to focus on is again
election security going into
the next few years in hopes of some sort
of
calmer area and some more secure area
when it comes to
the next sorts of congressional and
presidential elections
all right nbc's taylor millard speaking
to us from dallas texas thank you
thank you
you